political Washington obviously buzzing
tonight about the departure of John
Bolton as the president's national
security adviser joining us tonight to
tell us what he knows
Senate Foreign Relations Committee
member and chair of the Senate Judiciary
Committee Lindsey Graham of South
Carolina senator thanks for being here
and keeper having me see this coming a
bit it's a personality policy difference
that led to a change from my point of
view John Bolton served the country well
he gave the president good advice but
the one thing you learn about President
Trump is I've come to learn he's
unconventional in a conventional way
it's okay I think to talk with the
Taliban even in Camp David if there's a
reason to believe they're going to
accept peace and change their behavior
and I thought we just got ahead of the
cart there but you know John's gone and
there are a lot of good choices and I
appreciate what John did for the country
even a couple days ahead of 9/11 to do
that at Camp David yeah I can understand
that the timing but the main thing is I
told the pro you're right to want to
reduce our commitment you're right to
want to lower our cost eighteen years
later what do we what have we found al
Qaeda is still there Isis is there but
the Afghan army is 270,000 810 years ago
they didn't have an army there's six
million women in school there's a lot of
positive things there's a lot of bad
things and we can't do in Afghanistan
what we did in Iraq ignore sound
military advice and pull the plug on the
place but having said that I'd like to
end the war and the only ever end the
war is to get the two sides talking so
it's okay to talk with the Taliban it'd
be okay to come to Camp David but what I
thought was a mistake is the well the
big mistake was the Taliban really
screwed up when it came to Trump this
was an insult to the President to kill
that soldier why he's trying to end the
war I think they're gonna regret this I
think the Taliban are gonna really
regret what they did what do you say to
allies who look at the turmoil inside
the administration there have been 60
individuals in the Trump administration
of either resigned or been fired some of
them on the page here what do you say to
those allies who say hey listen this is
volatile it's uncertain we're looking
now at the fourth
National Security Adviser in three years
plus well here's how I'd say to allies
judges by what we do we reduced our
presence in Syria but we still have a
commitment to northeastern Syria to
protect the Kurds and make sure Iran
doesn't take over we got up at Orion
deal that I thought was a bad deal and
the president kept his word he's trying
to reduce our commitment in Afghanistan
and that makes sense to me we're paying
way too much money eighteen years later
and we can reduce our forces and be safe
here but we just can't pull out of the
place I'd say to our allies why don't
you help him more is was Iran a policy
difference between the president and
John Bolton because maybe the president
wants to meet with President Ronnie
maybe even at the UN General Assembly
I think Bolton looked at Trump to the
traditional foreign policy lens I've
abandoned that you know but condition
wisdom you don't talk to bad guys you
elevate kim jungim I don't care if
President Trump kim jungnam go on
vacation if that's what it takes to give
him up is give up the nuclear weapons
I'm okay with personal diploma this
unconditional I'm okay with talking to
the Iranians as long as we get a better
deal what would a better deal be they
can have nuclear power but they can
enrich or reprocess uranium that would
be a better deal so I'm not here to
lecture the president you beat me you
beat 16 other Republicans you beat
Hillary Clinton let's give your way a
try and I'm going to support them all
again but looking at North Korea as an
example as a blueprint how do you what
do you see out of those negotiations and
those two summits no well then where I
see better no nuclear missile testing no
bombs being exploded a personal
relationship that may lead to something
new and different everybody before Trump
how well did it work out so those who
want to criticize criticize the
president how well did you do in Iran
how well did you do in North Korea you
know I'm a pretty hawkish guy but after
18 years it's okay to reevaluate our
commitment in Afghanistan it makes
perfect sense to me but I'm just earning
the president don't ignore sounding
military advice you can reduce her
presence in Afghanistan but if you leave
Afghanistan al-qaeda and Isis are coming
after us
so did he fire him or did Bolton resign
I don't know and I don't think it really
matters at the end of the day I like
John Bolton he served honorably and this
president lost trust and faith in John
Bolton
and I think he's got some good choices
we talked about that you talked about
that today so we was on the
plate okay so general Kellogg is the
national security advisor to Mike Pence
the vice president he worked for general
McMaster Keith Killah yeah Keith Kellogg
he's a retired general competent capable
confident has the president's trust I
like him a lot Bryan hooks is a dynamic
young man working in the State
Department is part of the Iran team in
the State Department close to Pompeo
you've got Rick Waddell who worked for
McMaster that knows the ins and outs of
the National Security Council in the way
it meets the one thing that I think was
a knock on John Bolton as the inner
agency process kind of died on his watch
these are the three guys by the way
Keith Kellogg Brian Hook record oh yeah
so what I would say those are the three
names that the president mentioned to me
there are others on the list but what
are we looking for somebody that can
work with Pompeo can work with the
Department of Defense that can get the
interagency back stood back up this
doesn't require a Senate confirmation
vote this is just about trust with the
president right it's about understanding
the president trying to enact his will
but tell him the truth and here's the
truth and here's how I get along with
him this president you're right to want
to reduce our committment Afghanistan
reduced the cost and maybe reduce the
troop levels but it'd be a big mistake
to do in Afghanistan what Obama did in
Iraq so I'm looking for national
security adviser who understands the
president can work with others give the
president good advice and behind closed
doors push back when he needs to I want
to ask you two more questions one is
there's an investigation now of Commerce
Secretary Wilbur Ross if he put his
finger on the scale and NOAA scientists
and what in the fallout of the Alabama
ordeal we dealt with last week what's
your thoughts of that not good give her
crap okay that's for the record yeah
thank you
next question I mean you can't careless
this whole thing is a bunch of garbage
the President did have a model where it
could hit Alabama if it went through
Florida this is the Trump world the guy
can't do anything with a guy getting
criticized by a bunch of people who just
hate his guts and I'm not playing that
game the story about the Russian asset
that was extract another example of what
I think is complete BS
trying to blame the president for
something that didn't happen you know
other networks aren't there you know
saying the president got a loan
co-signed by oligarchs when it comes to
Trump I'm very suspicious you-you-you
say it then you try to verify it later
you know the president is a handful he
makes his fair share of mistakes but
this story about the president damaging
our national security I think is
unverified and untrue you confident that
the funding of the government is going
to go without a bump it may be a bump
but it's going to happen because
failures not an option and both parties
need to convince the public we're not
completely crazy appear and we can do
our job last thing anything get done
before 2020 in earnest I think we may
have some breakthroughs on solving the
plastic in the oceans problem we may
have some breakthroughs on
infrastructure a smaller bill funding
the government would be a great step
forward giving the military what they
need on immigration you might have a
deal with the daca population if the
court rules that Obama's daca plan was
unconstitutional you might have some
breakthroughs on prescription drugs
lowering the cost of prescription drugs
there's actually bipartisanship there
senator we appreciate the time thank you